hey guys it's vadim angelica and max and
welcome to our unbiased camera
comparison and the reason i say advice
is because i took both the brand new
iphone 13 pro max and the galaxy s21
ultra over the weekend and i took a
bunch of photos and i put them together
and they do not know which ones which if
you guys want to play along go ahead and
get a piece of paper and a pen and write
down your results and be sure to let us
know down in the comments yeah we want
to hear you guys opinions this is always
really fun to be completely unbiased and
last time the s21 ultra smoked the
iphone 12 pro max absolutely destroyed
it so it's gonna be exciting to see how
the 13 pro max compares all right so
this is the first photo this is actually
this morning with a beautiful sunrise so
it looks like one of these phones makes
cars disappear so you have nice sunrise
photos
um personally i like the one on the left
better it's a little bit brighter you
get a little bit more color there i
totally agree the left one looks much a
little too dark they're on the right one
yeah the round's a bit dark all right
let's see
all right thirteen pro masks for the
first one all right let's move on this
one's actually on this roof wow and
ultra wide this time look at that
flaring right there that's terrible this
is nice and clean i like the extra
contrast on the right
right yep
oh my goodness you know what's
interesting i have to comment on this
the 12 pro max had a lot of flaring
issues a lot they made the lenses larger
the rings they changed those that looks
like a big improvement pretty good all
right all right what about this
instantly the left one this is a 10 s oh
yep
samsung so we've got this point there i
actually have the 10x optical let's make
sure that we're right before i marked it
okay yep yep that's samsung all right so
we got a selfie okay here's the sun
all right so
i know which one i'm voting for
absolutely angelica what do you think
the left one is very blown out but the
right one has so much flaring which one
would you want in your phone
or which one would you want vadim to
have in this phone
oh man i don't know pluses and minuses
here okay you think i would absolutely
go with the left one the faces are so
much brighter they're colorful they're
they look like they're full of life even
though that's blowing out and i don't
like that the flaring hair is ugly it's
just too dark yeah i hate that but yeah
you're right choosing left again yeah
again
all right next one this is actually a 3x
portrait shot interesting okay these are
these both look really good yeah i i
think i like the one on the right better
really they both look great gosh they do
this looks dslr light yeah like the
quality the compression in the
background i will go with the one on the
left i like how the highlights on the
the hair and the arm
all right go hey first one
oh this is a macro shot so this is our
first macro so the iphone just
introduced the macro lens but the s21
already had it yeah they copied apple
copied samsung again what's interesting
is this almost looks like a portrait
shot i mean this has some blur too but
you have a lot of blur they're focusing
on yeah it's almost too much i'm
changing my mind at first i was gonna go
with the left one i like the contrast i
like this i like how it's separated more
from the background
uh you can add a little contrast if you
want it so i'm going with the one on the
right i'm gonna go with the left s
guess i'm a samsung guy okay this is a
1x so the regular wide portrait i
definitely like the one on the left oh
my god more the one on the right it
seems like the hair is kind of messed up
and just because of that it looks a
little funky
that's true it was a little windy yeah i
guess it's hard to do this where here
it's straight it's lower um and it's
like flaring that's true
all right i'm changing my mind i'm going
to the left
all right
this one is actually a 3x telephoto
without portrait or anything so left
left one yeah yeah it looks like this
has more detail this has more sharpening
and more contrast so both of them have
those three times lenses
yeah i vote for left left
it's so interesting how they keep going
back and forth as far as like which one
has more contrast yeah interesting yeah
they do oh another macro this is
actually an
eyeball shot and one of these couldn't
focus as close
oh interesting can we tell which phone
is which
they're both at the minimal focusing
distance okay
that's tough
uh i'm gonna say left yeah i guess i
like the this is looks a little sharper
maybe add extra contrast but to be able
to get that close is awesome let's do
left oh yeah
that's interesting so it can go closer
closer yep quite a bit closer all right
so this is going to be a
basically a portrait selfie video
comparison
so let's just let this play
wow okay
do you gotta pause it or no
it'll be good
what do you guys think well the one on
the right you like the one on the right
yeah there's something that i noticed is
the one on the right is very shaky
like a lot of shake like image
stabilization is not working whereas the
one on the left it's nice and smooth
i like the detail on the right one way
more
and like when it focuses on suenita
looks great when she comes up next to
you it's instantly like you can see here
then the left took a while and it just
didn't look as good both of them have
good qualities but i'm going with the
one on the left because that one's just
too shaky for me so i'd rather have a
little bit softer
but having it nice and smooth all right
left is actually 13 pro max all right
this is 21. one thing i do want to point
out to you guys that was kind of it that
i noticed was interesting you can see
that at this point
i'm still in focus completely and she is
which looks kind of weird and everything
else
compared to this one which it kind of
like goes back that's complete opposite
yeah this year blurred out but
everything's in focus which is more like
a real camera this is yeah that's so
weird the grass everything yeah i
literally look at her everything around
both of us is completely blurred whereas
this one has like a depth kind of yeah
oh man right next one this is just a
wide regular image gosh this is hard
this is pretty tough but i think i
prefer the one on the right i'm voting
for left
uh because even though i like that this
part isn't as blown out
um anieta is darker here like the whole
image is darker here she's brighter
she's kind of the subject and in real
life you do the hot spots are pretty
bright like this you also have extra
sharpness and detail in the background
so left
that's 21 20
all right this is actually at church so
it got a lot of bright lights lots of
colors it's a very tough situation this
i believe is the 3x i like the one on
the left
more for sure i agree why the highlights
pop more it pops so the subjects here
stand out uh more so compared to other
stuff in the highlights of the lights
and stuff like that it just seems like
you can get more detail like what is
what is that right there
laptop yeah yeah you see the logo not
there gotta see that apple logo right
here
that's the s21 wow that's 21. it's
pretty good okay this is a car shot
interesting differences here there's so
much more detail on the left a lot more
details ultra white here ultra white so
ultra wide yeah here you have detail in
the steering wheel your jeans even then
even the background at the same time
everything is much sharper compared to
like a much softer image waist and
highlights pop more too
and a lot of details here are crushed
like you can see down there yeah and the
left one's way better interesting so
left right
and that's weird because the s21 crushed
the iphone 12 pro max and ultra wide
detail before crushing it all right we
got a 3x
portrait shot yeah i've got my son
eugene out here these look so good
sunset coming out yes that 3x lenses
great for portraits wow the right one
looks great to me i it feels like this
has a baby a little bit more detail but
overall i like that image more the skin
tones look better especially during
sunset so i'll go for the right one both
on the right it's the iphone kills it
for portraits looks like it
here's another fun one
the one x then right yep this is the one
x now so you can tell it's wide left oh
the left one looks great yeah left looks
better look at that
13 pro max that's the iphone look at the
sunset you can actually see instead of
being blown out skin tones look better
and look at all this realistic bokeh
right here where that's completely
missing that like sells the effect makes
it much more like a dslr shot
because it shoots
shoes
it's issues
this is a portrait this is a 3x portrait
okay i mean absolutely left one yeah oh
yeah you only have to vote
yeah same thing look at that boca look
at all these real pokeballs
the cutout looks good the light isn't
blown out it's way bright it's better in
every single way yeah pretty good it's
the iphone again 13 pro max that looks
good
apple have they've redeemed themselves
yeah you were not finished but we know
this is a crazy upgraded swap pro max
all right got a 1x
portrait the one on the right yeah shank
is not in it but yeah
it's interesting that like this looks so
hazy and the blur is so weird right up
here everything is just so mixed in yeah
and they blurred the edge this has a
natural
depth to it looks a lot more realistic
yeah that's the other team
yeah i don't know apple does a great job
of like measuring the depth and just
slowly blurring you know what i wonder
if that's lidar if that lighter part of
it helps yeah maybe all right this is
actually an ultra wide and that i kind
of cropped in because it was for for
detail maybe oh definitely left look at
this yeah look at all that not only does
it not it's not all flat this is all
flat this you have brighter heading to
darker a lot more sharp colors pop out
more that looks great watch the iphone
again wow yeah that ultra i got a lot
better too the colors pop like crazy
like look at that that's it's impressive
all right so this is going to uh
basically a portrait rear facing video
so cinematic mode on the iphone and i
know it doesn't match up because you
know he's a kid running around but let's
play it
so we watched this a couple times
because obviously this is a very hard
situation to judge this is the hardest
situation ever to be shooting with
cinematic mode and both did a lot better
than i expected
in some situations the one on the left
looks pretty flat with the one on the
right like sometimes he'll stand out a
lot more and they'll be more contrast
and i'll just look better
yeah this is very very hard to judge
i'm going to go with the one on the
right just because that extra contrast
but it's it's a toss-up because they're
so it's so different between each other
the one thing i noticed at the start is
that the one on the left had a lot more
blur even when he was far away like it
seemed a little bit too much where the
one on the right uh had a little bit
less yeah i totally agree the one on the
right
yep so i think we'll give it to in this
situation yeah we'll both vote right
it's the s21 wow okay it looks like a
apple's new cinematic mode isn't so good
yeah i think so samsung's been doing it
for about two years now or so right i
know the first one looked horrendous so
either way samsung gets the point all
right next one this is a uh just one x
regular shot i'm definitely going to
vote for the one on the right i like the
sky it looks more appealing
everything's a little bit more moody
feeling and the sign stands out but
everything's darker so it seems more
like a nighttime shot yeah i agree the
right one stands out so much more like
the one on the left looks pretty flat
and if you look at some like
little details the one on the right
seems to be yeah this is clean here
detail clean where this has noise and
all these shadows here
it's the iphone
nice right this is a kind of like a
darker
selfie lift yeah i like the white
balance definitely and has more detail
but it also has more noise in all of the
shadows than that that looks cleaner
but i would choose that one to keep in
my phone
that's the s21 nice samsung good job
right this is actually a portrait 3x
portrait i think it's 3x but this is so
much closer than that it's going to be
interesting to know which one is which
you were standing same spot
uh i actually had to move up on one of
them oh okay because it wouldn't
it wouldn't do it yeah oh okay
all right left one looks great yeah i'm
voting for left not just because it's
closer
but it looks more moody same thing as
before you have the darkness then you
got the highlights you got the color in
the background i haven't been there for
a couple of years i want to go back
cool spot
13 pro that is a dang good yeah one
thing i noticed throughout this
basically filming and shooting yesterday
is that
it gets the color spot on of the signs
the neon that really glows with the
bright red
it gets it spot on i don't know how it
does it whereas the s21 kind of fades
everything into place it looks so flat
there yeah
all right so here is a
1x portrait a left one for sure the one
on the right the background is just so
blurry that it's like it's really
distracting it doesn't look that good
yeah and here
you have a nice gradation on his skin
tone and he looks more life like and
also the pants you have the highlights
compared to here
on the right one he looks so much
flatter his face and everything else so
left left
it's the iphone
jeez they got the portraits down now
yeah they do here's another one another
portrait nighttime portrait with the uh
1x i think definitely right for me yeah
the loved one everything is
much much darker however your subjects
like that's the most important thing so
i would take it being brought up you
want them to stand out right
yep that's also the actual gosh it does
have night mode portraits so it combines
both of the features whereas i guess the
s21 in this situation it didn't do that
or just doesn't have it oh
this is actually a 3x
jeep four trays that's a huge difference
yeah what happened really what happened
absolutely the one on the right
absolutely absolutely i mean this is so
blurry yeah this looks like the original
iphone taking a picture or i don't know
maybe iphone three or four
yeah wow so i think in this situation it
somehow used the telephoto where it
should have probably used the
one x and cropped it for the iphone i
don't know but yeah it gets destroyed
all right this is a night mode
image of a tree like this was extremely
dark to the eye
so i brought it up well the left one
looks great i like the left one oh yeah
a lot more detail the colors are better
the contrast is better it's the iphone
wow
all right this is an ultra wide night
mode
left left left oh the right one looks
fake it looks weird huh it looks so
weird
left is s21
then we have our tomato plant night mode
also with the one x
whoo left left two left look at this
before you switch yep this is all dark
here like crazy here you have the detail
different shadowing i like the white
balance better and down here too
everything is yep
s21 wow interesting and this is a 3x
night mode they both look kind of bad
yeah
i'll go with the one on the left i like
the sky better yeah uh both look ah this
looks like it has maybe a little bit
more detail as well but they're both not
great the right one is so flat so left
then both yeah
it's the iphone this time interesting
how it flip flops yeah it's interesting
how it like it makes night look like
night you know it still looks good it's
true and i think this is the final photo
right here
oh becca sleeping
okay
well this looks more like morning or
something and this looks more like night
just yeah this keeps it looking like
it's dark with a little bit of lighting
in the background i do like that one
better just because it's cleaner look at
all the noise here this is nice and
clean
um you can always adjust the white
balance a little bit if you want it to
look uh warmer i guess but which one are
you going for i'm going for the right
one day me too
okay
that's the iphone iphone and that's it
it's the last one so
with that said guys count up your votes
and you guys as well pause the video
count it up count it all up put it into
the comments before you watch the
results let us know if our opinions suck
on these photos and you voted completely
differently all right guys let's reveal
the results like is going to go first me
yep i got 21 points for the 13 pro max
and 9 for the s21 ultra that's a big
difference that's like huge more than
double
you know what's interesting that's
pretty much what happened last time when
the iphone when it gets s21 ultra and
the z fold
this s21 had like double the points of
the iphone um and i got 19 for the
iphone and 11. so i got two more points
21 but still pretty much the same ratio
that was crazy so we made a few
observations apple fixed a lot of the
issues that they had for example the
ultra wide it would always get smoked in
the ultra wide it is much better now
the portrait shots they really improve
basically like every portrait every por
almost every portrait shot it won and
then um the other thing night mode they
made huge improvements there you have
great contrast the gradations look great
so they definitely improved it there the
iphone 12s they used to outside like
they would blow out so much and now that
it's so much better like it's not even
an issue our hdr4 same thing with
flaring the twelves
really really really really bad and now
they like don't at all that was
interesting how it actually beat the
samsung in it it had no player it's
almost like hey this is everybody's
complaining about this
let's fix it um and the samsung one in
the cinematic mode video uh for the rear
when eugene was running around but we
did look it up and actually you cannot
change that blur at all it's baked into
the video so even though it looks better
and it did win that point
having it baked in when those little
mistakes happen not being able to adjust
it or fix it really sucks and of course
a front-facing video cinematic mode was
garbage shaky and weird focused on both
subjects no matter how far they were
blurred everything out we have to give
samsung the shout out for the zoom lens
that
uh 10x lenses is amazing like if you're
somebody that likes to zoom in you go to
zoos
or trips wherever that apple can't even
touch that at all all right guys so
thank you guys for watching we want to
know your guys opinions down below of
course if you guys want to see a full
comparison between both of those phones
that is coming out tomorrow so make sure
you guys hit that subscribe button um
and so you guys don't miss out and that
also can help us reach our goal of a
million subscribers that would be
amazing check out one of those great
videos right over there and we will see
you in the next video
[Music]
you